welcome to my top 10 firebase tips
welcome to my top 25 firebase tips nope
welcome to my top 100 firebase tips I've
been working with firebase for several
years now I've made plenty of mistakes
along the way but I've also uncovered
some secrets that you may not know about
so hopefully this video makes your
experience with firebase 100 times
easier if you're new here like and
subscribe and if you're serious about
building an app with firebase consider
becoming a pro member at fire ship item
you'll get access to full project
courses and a free t-shirt if you sign
up for life
or you can get a free t-shirt by leaving
the best firebase tip in the comments
below the first thing you'll need is a
firebase project if you're building a
serious app create two fire based
projects one for development and one for
production this gives you a sandbox for
testing and experimenting and you can
keep your customer data pristine in the
production project in your production
project link Google Analytics firebase
can automatically set up analytics for
iOS Android and the web if you're
working with a team head over to the
Settings tab and then go to users and
permissions assign rules based on the
principle of least privilege so team
members only have access to the
resources that they actually need from
their head over to the data privacy tab
and update your contact information to
ensure you're in compliance with gdpr
now click the button to add a new app to
your firebase project when you do that
it will give you an object with a bunch
of credentials don't worry these are
perfectly safe in your front-end code as
long as you set up security rules which
we'll look at later upgrade your
firebase plan to blaze its pay-as-you-go
but you still get all the free stuff
that you would on the spark tier but you
still want to stay on top of costs so
head over to the GCP console and set up
a budget alert for your project and
monitor your monthly usage from the
reports panel this will tell you exactly
which services are costing you the most
money make sure to install the firebase
command line tools globally on your
system and also the Google Cloud SDK a
firebase project is actually just a
layer on top of a Google cloud platform
project once you've done this you should
have access to the firebase command and
the g-cloud command on your local system
so now that we have a project set up
let's look at how we can actually deploy
our code to this project if you're
building an iOS or Android app use
firebase app distribution to distribute
your app to testers this will bypass
test flight and the Google Play Store
making your life much easier
now if you're building a web application
you're likely using a package manager
like NPM install firebase tools into the
development environment
for that project and now you can write
NPM scripts that use the firebase CLI
tools now if you followed my earlier
advice to set up different projects for
development of production you can use
the project flag to set up different
commands that specify the project so
here we have a command to deploy to our
development project and another for our
production project now after you
deployed your site head over to the
firebase console and you can see it's
deployed at a cool domain called your
project web app or you can just connect
your own custom domain and you're not
limited to a single domain for example
you might have an admin site and a
customer facing site they can both share
the same firebase project with multi
site hosting then go into your firebase
JSON file change the hosting value to an
array and set up different targets that
represent the different sites you want
to deploy now you're not just limited to
static files when deploying to hosting
you can actually rewrite traffic to a
cloud function or to a cloud run
instance and that means you can do SSR
was something like angular Universal or
next j/s you can also set up firebase
hosting rewrites for dynamic links this
allows you to dynamically send the user
to the app with the best possible
experience so if the user goes to a link
on their iPhone it will take them to a
specific screen in the iPhone app you
can also specify headers on these static
files in your hosting account for
example if we wanted to change the
course settings for all the font files
we could do it like this and firebase
hosting will also cache our static files
for better performance but we can change
the caching behavior by setting
different cache headers here as well and
one cool thing you might do to extend
firebase hosting is to set it up with
Google cloud build so every get commits
you make to your project it will deploy
a new version of your site to your
hosting account that's exactly what I do
for a fire ship io firebase provides two
different fully managed no SQL databases
so how do you know which one to choose
I default to cloud fire store because it
has more powerful query capabilities it
also cost less per gigabytes stored
however real-time database does not
charge for writes so it can be a great
option if you have data that's updated
frequently like an IOT sensor or
something along those lines but when it
comes to pricing you really shouldn't
worry about it too much don't even trip
dog
firebase overall is very inexpensive and
it will take a decent number of monthly
active users before you even break out
of the free tier unless you make a silly
mistake you'll be paying much less than
you would be with other cloud solutions
a more important thing to work
about is that you backup your data on a
regular basis set up a dedicated cloud
storage bucket for backups and then you
can backup your entire database with a
single command when you create your
database for the first time set it in
locked mode it's safer to start with a
lockdown database then incrementally
allow operations as they become
necessary after you've created a
firestorm go ahead and click the filter
icon and you'll see that you can make
queries directly from the firebase
console and it even provides some code
for your query that you can copy and
paste to using your app source code in
fact let's go ahead and switch gears and
jump into the source code for a
JavaScript application now the way you
import firebase depends on the flavor of
JavaScript that you're using you can see
the import syntax here for a common j/s
es6 and typescript but all of these are
actually wrong because they're importing
from firebase directly your code will
work but it will create a huge
JavaScript bundle that will slow down
your app the correct way to use firebase
is to import from the firebase app
namespace and then import these services
that you plan on using aka progressive
enhancement in any case firebase is a
pretty big dependency so if you're
loading it with a script tag you'll want
to use the defer keyword on that script
to ensure it loads after the actual Dom
or HTML has been parsed but if you're
using a framework then you shouldn't
have to worry about this angular app
should use angular fire which integrates
with change detection and the angular
router if you use react on the front-end
the react fire library was just under
cated and it provides support for hooks
and suspense
you have rx fire to integrate with rxjs
which works great in frameworks like
spelt then outside of the web you have
support for all kinds of different other
frameworks in firebase extended like
flutter Arduino and many others when you
first add firebase to a project there's
a couple of no-brainer services that
you'll definitely want to use such as
performance monitoring with a single
line of code we can see how well our app
performs out in the wild giving us
metrics like first contentful paint
across all devices using our app the
next one is crashlytics which is only
relevant to native mobile apps it's very
easy to set up and it will give you
error reporting and crash reporting
throughout your entire application and
automatically open issues so you can
address those problems and lastly we
have firebase analytics with a single
line of code we'll get the default
reporting from Google Analytics giving
us insight about the behavior of our
users now in your source code one of the
first things you'll likely want to do is
determine if a
user is logged in or not there are two
main ways to do this you can pull the
current user at any time by calling off
current user this is usually best for
handling events like when the user
clicks a button and then you want to
grab their auth record and do something
afterwards the other way to get the
current user is to always be listening
to the current off state in this case
you provide a callback function to
listen to changes to the off state like
when the user signs in or signs out in
either case I recommend getting good at
asynchronous JavaScript to be successful
with firebase understanding async await
is very useful for the first approach in
understanding callbacks and functional
programming is very useful for the
second approach when a user attempts to
login something might go wrong it might
be your fault as the developer or the
users fault in any case you want to make
sure that you catch these errors and
then create a default handler that
routes them to a visual UI element like
a dialog a cool trick you can do with
firebase auth is to register a user
lazily for example you might first have
a user sign in anonymously which will
give you a user ID that you can tie to
the database then later in the
onboarding process you can collect their
email or link social accounts like
Twitter Facebook Google etc now certain
authentication methods like email
password may need to send emails to your
users for things like email verification
and resetting passwords sometimes you
might want to control this process on
your own which you can do with custom
email action handlers and you can even
bring your own custom SMTP email server
now one of the most important aspects of
any application is managing relational
data let's check out a few common
techniques for connecting our users to
the firestore database we can create a
one-to-one relationship where the user
has one document and firestore by first
retrieving their user ID then we'll make
a reference to a collection and set the
document ID as the user ID every user ID
is unique so it guarantees that that
user can only have one document in that
collection now if it's possible that
data already exists there you might want
to use the merge true option this will
ensure that any data that already exists
there won't be overwritten the emerge
true option just makes it a
non-destructive update another common
relationship is one-to-many a user might
have many orders but an order belongs to
one user the best way to handle this
type of relationship is to use a sub
collection in the last example we
created a document with a use
and we know that every subcollection
under that document is owned by that
user but sometimes you might run into a
situation where you want to query orders
across all the users in your database
firebase provides a special method that
allows you to group sub collections and
query them together collection group
will find all of the collections that
share the name orders grouped them
together allowing you to make a single
query against all of them in another
very common relationship is many to many
in this case we have a single collection
called chats and each chat document can
be associated with multiple users we can
associate multiple users to multiple
chats by embedding their user IDs on the
chat document using a map of key value
pairs the key is the user ID and then
I'm going to duplicate the display name
in case we want to show that in the UI
data duplication is perfectly OK and no
SQL it can optimize for performance and
costs but it works best with values that
are immutable or that don't need to be
updated very often and now that we have
a map object on this document where each
key in that map is a user ID we can
query it by using dot notation in our
queries like ordered by members dot user
ID
now that we've modeled some data and
made some queries we need to decide if
we want our data in real time format or
not if you're trying to optimize pricing
and don't think you'll need real-time
updates for your data you can just call
query get to retrieve the data once and
then not listen to any future updates
but if you are building a feature where
the UI should react to changes in real
time you'll want to use query on
snapshot then run a callback function
anytime the underlying data changes on a
collection query when you listen to
Doc's you'll get a new array anytime
there's a change to the underlying data
but you might want to know exactly which
documents were added modified or removed
doc changes provides an array of all the
documents that changed their old index
new index and the change type another
awesome thing about firestore is that
it's able to work offline if the
internet goes out and the user is still
trying to send writes to the database
firestore will still update the UI and
then send those rights to the actual
database and commit them after the
internet comes back online and you can
even make this work across multiple
browser tabs by setting the synchronized
tabs option to true now one question I
get a lot is how do I use emoji
characters in my code well they're
actually just utf-8 characters which
means you can use them in a regular
string and that also means that you can
use them in your fire store documents
and make queries against them another
trick you might want to use is to match
a wild-card string for example if we
wanted to query all of the fast and the
furious movie titles create a starting
point and then make your ending point a
tilde character this will match all the
documents that start with the fast and
the furious title and with that we have
reached the halfway mark let's take a
quick break welcome back sometimes you
might have a compound query where you
chain together multiple query conditions
this query won't work by default because
it requires an index but don't create
the index manually let your app throw an
error then click the link to the
firestore console to create the index
automatically one of the most powerful
data types in fires store is a list we
can add a list to a document by simply
setting it with a JavaScript array but
we might decide later that any good
firebase recipe needs to include a
pineapple we can use the firestore array
union method to ensure that the array
includes exactly one pineapple or we
might decide later on that maybe squid
wasn't such a good idea in this recipe
so we can remove it by using the array
removed method without having to know
the actual index and now that we have an
array on the document we can query it by
using the array contains operator inside
of where and that will give us all of
the recipes that contain avocado now
sometimes you might have an array that
contains IDs of other documents in the
database but how do you actually fetch
the full documents in this array do it
in JavaScript by mapping all of the ID
strings to an array of promises that get
the document then run them together with
promise all one thing you should
generally avoid doing is setting a
timestamp from your friend code because
the users clock might not be
synchronized properly if you need to set
a timestamp on a document use the
firestore server timestamp that ensures
that all users are sharing the same
clock another thing you might want to do
is increment a counter like the score of
the game
you can change the value of the counter
atomically without knowing its current
value by using the increment field value
now firestore only supports one write
per document per second although you can
burst above that value so if you have a
ton of writes happening on a single
document you can set up a distributed
counter which is now very easy to do
because there is a firebase extension
that's a
and speaking of atomic sometimes you
might have rights that need to succeed
or fail together maybe the user
completes the game you write the score
and then you want to update the users
lifetime score you can ensure that these
operations happen together by setting up
a batch right this will commit them
together but roll back to the previous
state if any of the writes fail now
firestore is a great solution for the
vast majority of use cases but sometimes
you might need a full relational
database if you need a full relational
database check out my video on
integrating MySQL into a firebase
project or if you need full text search
check out my algo Lea integration video
now one of the most important things to
do as a firebase developer is set rules
before you deploy to production if you
deploy an app without good security
rules in place your customers data could
be compromised and someone could make
destructive writes to your database
currently our databases in lock mode
which means we're safe but now let's go
ahead and open up some operations for
our users the first thing you should do
is get used to using the simulator it
allows you to pass mock requests to the
database to see how the rules will be
evaluated but serious production apps
should use the firestore emulator this
allows you to simulate the firestore
database in your local development
environment so you can throw a whole
bunch of different test cases at your
rules to ensure that they're robust note
that there are five different types of
operations a user can make on a document
they can get a single document a query
of a list of documents and they can
create update and delete documents you
can provide fine-grained rules for each
operation or you can combine them by
using the read or write keywords if they
share the same logic just separate them
with a comma when a rule is evaluated
there are two things that you look at
the request and the resource the request
contains the user's authentication state
as well as the incoming data that
they're trying to write to the database
the resource on the other hand is the
data that already exists at this path in
the database but in some cases you might
need to look elsewhere in the database
to determine if a rule should be allowed
use the get keyword and then point to a
path in the database and you can use
dollar sign parentheses to interpolate
values like the request aunt user ID
this gives you the value from this
document but keep in mind that you're
charged a read every time this rule is
evaluated now you might notice that this
is a very long line of code and if we
were using this frequently throughout
the rules we wouldn't want to have to
repeat it all the time we can extract
this logic into its own function call
is admin and now we have a much cleaner
way to check for admin users now let's
switch gears to cloud storage a storage
bucket is where you would put things
like images videos and RAW files you
have a default bucket which is where you
would normally save your user-generated
content but you can create additional
buckets as well you might want an
additional bucket for firestore backups
which you can set to cold line which
will save you some money now when you
upload a file to a storage bucket there
is a storage location in a download URL
if the user needs to access this file
again in the future
I recommend saving both values to the
firestore database you can use these
storage locations to replace or delete
the file in the future or the download
URL to access the file in your app but
don't worry too much if you forgot to
save the file path in the database
because you can use the storage ref from
URL and point to either the full path in
the storage bucket or to the download
URL to access that file sometimes you
might want to list out all the files in
a directory in the bucket simply make a
reference to the path to the directory
and then use the list all method to get
all the files at that location you can
upload a file by simply making a
reference to a file path and then
putting the raw file that you want to
upload you can calculate the progress of
an upload by listening to the state
changed event then divide the bytes
transferred by the total bytes in the
file if you have multiple files to
upload feel free to upload them all at
the same time
firebase will automatically handle
concurrency and upload them as
efficiently as possible
when you upload files you might also
want to save your own custom metadata
about that file you might want to know
what kind of device the user upload the
file from their user ID and stuff like
that if your users can upload image
files there's a good chance that you'll
want to resize them to different
resolutions for different devices you
can now do that with a click of a button
that using the firebase image resizer
extension at this point we've been
mostly looking at front-end code so now
I want to switch gears to the backend
you can create your own command line
utility for firebase with three easy
steps go to your project settings and
download the service account for your
project in a node project install
firebase admin as a development
dependency then create a J's file that
imports it and calls initialize app
firebase admin needs your service
account but it contains sensitive
information the safest way to use it
locally is to keep it somewhere private
on your system and then use an
environment variable called Google
application
but if you include the service account
directly in your source code make sure
it's in your git ignore so it doesn't
end up in a public repo somewhere one of
my favorite things to do with an admin
script is to seed the database with some
dummy data install faker J s and then
import it into your JavaScript file then
create a loop and for each iteration add
a new document to the collection using
faker to automatically generate the
dummy data now run the script from the
command line with node you should now
see a bunch of dummy documents seated in
your database now you can do a lot with
the firebase admin SDK but you can do
even more with the REST API s check out
the REST API documentation to find
secret techniques that you didn't know
about earlier I showed you how to backup
firestore from the command-line but you
can also do it with the REST API this
would allow you to set up a cron job to
backup your database on a daily basis if
you do use the REST API you'll want to
use the Google API NPM package this
allows you to discover and interact with
hundreds of different Google API s like
Adwords YouTube and of course firebase
creating an admin script can be useful
but in most cases you'll be working with
firebase admin in a cloud function you
can add cloud functions to your project
by running firebase and net functions
when you do this I highly recommend
using typescript because it does all the
setup for you and will help you catch
silly errors before they end up in
production there's a few things we can
do to improve the performance of a cold
start on a cloud function and also
reduce the CPU time that were actually
billed for try to minimize the number of
dependencies that you use in your
functions more code to load and parse
means a slower cold start time if you
have values that can be shared between
multiple function invocations you can
set them up as global variables when a
function instance spins up in the cloud
it might be used multiple times so
global variables can be used across
multiple calls improving performance
when you design your cloud functions
they should always be item potent cloud
functions are guaranteed to be invoked
at least once but they can be retried
multiple times so you want to make sure
that multiple calls to the same function
produces the same result and you can use
the context event ID to help you achieve
that if you need to add more horsepower
to a function you can use run with to
max out the memory at two gigabytes and
the timeout seconds to 540 now one thing
you want to be really careful not to do
is to create an infinite loop you might
accidentally do this in firestore by
updating the same document that
triggered the event in this example we
have an on write function
updates the same document that triggered
the right so this will cause an infinite
loop that will charge up your firebase
bill until you hit the quota limits it's
not a good thing to do however there are
use cases when you might want the
triggering function to update the same
document you can avoid the infinite loop
by checking if the after document is
equal to the before document this will
check for equality on the document path
and its data and that will stop the loop
assuming your function is idempotent
background cloud functions must always
return a promise you can ensure that
always happens by using the async
keyword in the function callback then
you can use the await keyword for a much
cleaner synchronous looking code
sometimes you might need a cloud
function that communicates with other
cloud functions or other GCP services
you could use an HTTP function to handle
that but you would also need to
implement some code to validate the
request a better alternative would be to
set up a pub sub function it allows you
to pass messages between your internal
services and that's easier and more
secure than exposing an HTTP endpoint
you might also have endpoints that
should only be accessed by authenticated
users in a regular HTTP function you
would need to extract the authorization
header that you set in your front-end
code and then verify the ID token as an
alternative you can simplify both your
back-end and front-end code by using
callable functions it includes the auth
context for the user so you don't have
to implement your own middleware to
authenticate your functions a great use
case is to delete an entire firestore
collection which should always be done
on the backend because there might be
tons of documents in a collection we can
first authorize the operation by looking
at the user ID then we'll create a
recursive function called batch delete
it retrieves documents and batches of
100 and then deletes that this will
ensure that we don't hit memory issues
if we try to query millions of documents
in a single go now when implementing the
actual logic for your back-end code
consider breaking it down into small
JavaScript functions this allows you to
reuse code across multiple deployed
cloud functions and it's also just
easier to test keep in mind that cloud
functions provide a gateway to interact
with other third party API s almost
every good API also has a good nodejs
library to go with it so basically
anything you can build an ojs you can
build in a cloud function when you're
ready to go live you can deploy all of
your functions from the command line
with a single command but on larger
projects with dozens of functions you
may not want to deploy everything all
once you can append the name of the
function to the end of this command to
deploy a single function despite your
best efforts your functions will very
likely have some bugs the best way to
prevent bugs is to run the cloud
functions shell locally you can invoke
your functions with mock data to test
their behavior and firebase even
provides a unit testing library now your
functions still might break in
production so you can always look at the
firebase logs to see what's going wrong
or better yet head over to stackdriver
where you can create your own custom
dashboards and alerts for the things
that you care about earlier in the video
we set up analytics in our front-end
code but to get the most out of it we'll
want to track custom events and user
properties try to pinpoint the events or
user behaviors that you think are most
important to turning that user into a
paying customer then use firebase
analytics to record those events
firebase will aggregate some of the data
automatically but you can create your
own audiences based on the type of user
that you want to target your marketing
team will love audiences because you can
target messaging to a specific type of
user and also do things like a be
testing and funnels and as a developer
you can actually use audiences to
customize the UI based on your
underlying analytics data the service
will send key value pairs down to your
front-end application which you can use
to conditionally show UI based on where
that user is located what audience they
belong to and so on you can also use the
same data to send push notifications to
your users using firebase Cloud
messaging instead of sending a bulk
notification out to all of your users
segment it to the users who actually
want it and will benefit from it and
with that we have finally reached
firebase tip number 100 leverage
machine-learning within your app you can
do this in multiple ways with firebase
use predictions to guess when a user is
going to buy your product use ml kit to
implement a I driven features
out-of-the-box
things like object detection and smart
reply or build your own image
classification models with Auto ml and
you can even export all of your
analytics and fire store data to
bigquery and use that raw data to train
your own tensorflow models from scratch
and that is all of the firebase tips
that exists in the world if you have
your own additional tips leave them in
the comments below and I'll pick a
couple of the best ones to win a t-shirt
later this week I'm gonna go ahead and
wrap things up there hopefully you found
something useful
here thanks for watching and I will talk
to you soon
[Music]